grüße sie zur heutigen sitzung wir
werden uns heute noch mal kurz mit
aristoteles beschäftigen nachdem es
letzte mal ja ein bisschen sehr schnell
alles ging und sie haben eine
zusammenfassung bekomme ich habe in der
zusammenfassung noch einen kurzen eine
kurze ergänzung vorgenommen nämlich bin
ich noch auf einen anderen wichtigen
begriff eingegangen bei aristoteles
nämlich die profis und auf die müssen
wir heute auch noch ein bisschen näher
zu sprechen kann
was es damit genau auf sich hat mit
dieser progressive und zwar über setzt
man die häufig mit wahl oder auch mit
vorsatz das bis also es gibt zwei
besetzungs möglichkeiten crysis und wir
wollen also heute noch ein bisschen auf
dieses diesen begriff eingehen der der
ist einfach ganz wichtig wenn es darum
geht sind bestimmen was aristoteles
unter der der freien willens waren
versteht ich habe jetzt erst einmal
gesagt dass er es tot ist eigentlich gar
nicht so was wie in richtigen willens
begriff hat nach heutigem verständnis
ebenfalls sagen viele und darunter auch
eine art das augustinus dem in der
zweiten hälfte jetzt diese heutigen
sitzung behandeln werden dass der der
erfinder oder auch die entdecker des
willens sei wir wollen noch mal heute
kurz schauen was jetzt aristoteles alles
zum willens begriff und zum
freiheitsbegriff zu sagen hat also wir
haben so ein paar fragen was er steht
unter freiwilligkeit das ist die hacken
sie schreibt auch noch mal hin also
provinz hama
die ist ja da gibt es auch noch die
akkus
das ist dann die freiwilligkeit
das ist an die freiwilligkeit dass die
und freiwilligkeit ist die frage was ist
die profis ist das ist der ganz
entscheidende begriff heute die profis
ist und ich nehme es noch mal vorweg
also die ursula wolf das ist die
besitzerin dieser die komischen ethik
dieser ausgabe die wir uns hier vor
gesetzt haben die sagt wir übersetzt die
praxis haben sie die idee ist natürlich
schwierig wenn sie in griechischen
begriff jetzt nicht parat haben
unternehmens überlegen sie mal was heißt
denn vor
das heißt pro
pro und heiri griechisch heißt nehmen
eigentlich auch also nehmen also ist das
was man sich vornimmt
jetzt kann natürlich schlecht sagen dass
es die vornahme die vornahme da gibt es
nicht diese wort die die vornahme aber
was gibt's denn es gibt die vorwegnahme
gibt es aber nicht die vornahme aber es
gibt sie noch verein wort das mit vor
beginnt und so was wie eine planung
überlegung einschließen und so wird es
wurde auch übersetzen diesem text ja
genau dass sich vornehmen aber wenn sie
jetzt ist eben ein
sie haben jetzt ein längeres sagen
substantiven omen jetzt gebildet aber
wenn sie das in einem wort sein sollten
das vorhaben genau das wäre möglich oder
der vor der vorsatz ja so wird hier ist
jetzt der vorsatz also der vorsatz ist
jetzt natürlich sehr nahe und
griechischen dran
ich setze mir zb von einem vorsatz ist
nächste mal hier einen besseren stiften
zu bringen der hier besser schreibt also
vorsatz ja also es gibt ganz
verschiedene besetzung von vorsatz oder
es ist man kann auch sagen das ist die
die die bilanz war das was man sich
überlegt auch so ein bisschen und wir
wollen jetzt also heute darauf zu
sprechen kommt wie diese zwei begriffe
ecosia und praxis miteinander
zusammenhängen
jetzt gehen wir mal hier kurz durch
diese texte durch erst noch weitere
frage wie verhalten sich freiwilligkeit
und determination nach aristoteles
zueinander und dann noch wie verhalten
sich dass es jetzt die heutige frage die
besonders im zentrum steht wie verhalten
sich vorsatz und freiwilligkeit
zueinander
also wie verhalten sich pro harris und
hq sie zueinander
es gebe einfach mal so ein bisschen text
rein also es geht es um das gewollte und
da sind für aristoteles die bedingungen
der die abwesenheit von zwang und er
sagt folgendes wir haben das schon das
letzte mal gelesen ich bringe es einfach
noch mal zur wiederholung als ungewollt
gilt üblicherweise das was durch zwang
bh oder aufgrund von unwissenheit neuer
geschieht erzwungen ist dein verhalten
dessen bewegung sache arche außerhalb
blick das heißt so beschaffen ist dass
die handelte oder erleiden de gar nichts
beiträgt etwa wenn jemandem den wind der
wind irgendwohin trägt oder menschen die
in ihrer gewalt haben also hier haben
wir jetzt praktisch in form von
determinismus oder genauer gesagt von
notwendigkeiten und dieses argument hier
so ist denn eines ist kann man jetzt mit
pieter van in welches konsequenz
arguments und bisschen in verbindung
bringen als man kann sagen wenn eben die
determinieren die ursache für meine
handlung oder meine aktion nicht hin mir
liegt also nicht in mir das den grund
hat die arche hat dann könnte der grund
auch zb vor meiner geburt liegen also
wenn wir jetzt hier arche das ist also
der beweggrund oder die ursache der der
grund für diese handlung und er könnte
auch wenn ich jetzt hier bin
könnte er auch außerhalb von mir liegen
und daneben mich determinieren und dann
kommt die handlung oder was auch mal
hier raus aber aber die handlung ist
dann nicht durch mich zu verantworten
sondern eben durch diesen grund der
außerhalb von mir liegt und zwar auch in
der zeit die jetzt hier sind zeitstrahl
ihm mache dann sehen sie legt einfach
diese grund in etwas was eben vor meiner
geburt oder meine existenz liegt und das
ist auch in dieser modernen debatte so
könnte man es mit der modernen debatte
vergleichen
das wäre zum beispiel dieses konsequenz
argument jetzt ganz grob gesagt also
wenn etwas eben meinen willen bestimmt
und dieses bestimmende prinzip vor
meiner geburt liegt dann kann ich dafür
nicht verantwortlich sein
das ist halt so könnte man das jetzt
interpretieren
wenn man jetzt diese frage auf die
determinismus bringen bildung
also diese grund diese dieses prinzip
muss in dieser person zu finden sein und
mit welcher der bereits bestehenden
positionen die wir hier so kennen würden
sie jetzt dass diese betonung dieses
dieser art dieses also diese bewegt
ursache am meisten vergleichen von
welchen dieser drei typen von position
der materie debatte vielleicht wieder
rüber noch mal kurz welche drei
positionen hatten wir mindestens in der
modernen debatte zählen sie doch einfach
mal zu rufen
warum sich nicht zu melden hysterie an
ismus wird es des aristoteles würden sie
sagen ja nicht genau was haben wir noch
ja das ist eine spannende frage wann
inkompatibel ist ist was haben wir noch
von der position genau kompatibel ismus
und jetzt kann man sagen bei den
inkompatibel listen gibt es eben die
freiheit skeptiker also ich sagen
determinismus und freiheit sind nicht
miteinander vereinbar
und weil der determinismus war ist folgt
aus die falschheit der freiheit auswahl
geht ja von den weg nicht von den bergen
sagt der determinismus ist wahr ich bin
inkompatibel ist ish also müsste daraus
die falschheit der freiheit folgen aber
sie kann irgendwie nicht raus folgen
weil wir zu starke argumente dafür haben
freiheit anzunehmen und deswegen sagt er
obwohl ich es eigentlich logisch nicht
begründen kann nur sich dennoch freiheit
annehmen einfach aufgrund von
verschiedenen fakten der welt schuld und
so weiter zurechenbarkeit und dass ich
gezwungen bin freiheit trotz des
determinismus trotz der wahrheit dass
determinismus anzunehmen dass es ein
mysterium
also freiheit ist ein mysterium und
jetzt gibt es aber eben noch diese
position des eben kompatibel ist
wie zum beispiel robert kane das sind so
genannte vertreter der akteurs
kausalität als akteur ist kausalität
heißt dieses diese grund der
spontaneität der liegt in mir selbst
das ist sozusagen das ist diese these
und
wenn man dann akteurs kausalität so
versteht wie es einige tun kann man
sagen wir selbst sind die beweger wir
selbst sind die unbewegten beweger sind
wir sind dieser art wir selbst sind die
die st die instanzen die diese
kausalketten in die welt senden und so
könnte man das auch verstehen dann nach
aristoteles diese arche die liegt in uns
die arche der museums einbezogen werden
wir sind der grund für die handlung dann
könnte man das also als er hat die von
akteurs kausalitäten beschreiben
jedenfalls würde sich das mit so einer
form von notwendigkeit nicht vertragen
aristoteles hat natürlich noch an vielen
anderen stellen über determinismus
geschrieben nach aristoteles gibt es
also viele verschiedene formen von
determinismus es gibt einen logischen
determinismus gibt es gibt einen
metaphysischen determinismus auf die
wollen es heute nicht so eingehen wenn
sie den vortrag von dorothea friedel
hören noch mal wohl den ich jetzt in der
aufnahme dieser heutigen sitzung rechts
oben und sie ist an sich anschauen
einblenden werde in diesem youtube-video
rechts oben oder sehen sie können sie
das noch mal nachsehen was sie zu diesen
verschiedenen formen von determinismus
sagt ich glaube ich werde auch noch ihr
handout unten in den beschreibungstext
des videos einbinden da können sie sich
noch mal anschauen also sehr sie hat zu
den verschiedenen deterministischen
theorien oder theorien von determinismus
bei ihren vortrag gehalten als
jedenfalls hier geht es jetzt erst mal
um zwang zwang ist nicht gleichzusetzen
mit notwendigkeit zwar ist ihr was ein
stärkeres also das wäre würde ich jetzt
interpretieren sind notwendig
das ist nicht gleich determinismus jetzt
gibt's dieses zitat sieht man sich noch
an dieses schiff im meer im sturm wo man
dann hier seine güter über bord wirft
ja und was sagt jetzt aristoteles dazu
wenn sie jetzt eben gezwungen sind
aufgrund von bestimmten umständen die
güte eines schiffes
die waren über bord zu werfen damit sie
ihr leben retten können wäre diese
handlung dann nach aristoteles
freiwillig wurde wäre sie gezwungen was
würde man der abstimmung wäre es dafür
dass diese handlung noch freiwillig
genannt werden kann
er ist dagegen okay das diskutieren mal
ein bisschen was für gründe würden sie
anführen sprechen dafür dass sie nicht
freiwillig ist die st
sie fahren mit dem schiff kommen also im
schiff nicht wie heutzutage nicht so ein
kreuzfahrtschiff sondern so ein altes
gebot segelschiff und sie geraten ein
sturm und da sehen sie heimen lasten
raum hat es dann noch ein paar fässer
und wir brauchen jetzt ein bisschen
weniger gewicht oder weniger wir
brauchen ein bisschen mehr flexibilität
sonst gehen wir da unter welche
argumente sprechen jetzt dafür dass sich
dabei nicht um eine freiwillige anderen
handelt eine kann sich gemeldet was
würden sie sagen
warum würde könnte man mit guten gründen
durchaus erst mal sagen diese handlung
ist nicht freiwillig was würden sie denn
sagen wenn sie sagen es ist nicht
freiwillig hier könnten sie
argumentieren ja ja genau halb man
könnte sagen wenn dieser sturm nicht
wäre ja dann hätte ich das nicht machen
müssen wenn dieses unwetter nicht
gewesen wäre wäre ich jetzt nicht dazu
verleitet worden das über bord zu
schmeißen okay wäre also der wäre hier
überlegen sie mal nach diesem modell
wäre dann also der grund für ihr handeln
also das handels mal diese waren über
bord zu werfen
also waren sind ja eigentlich nach
aristoteles und auch nach uns heutzutage
noch güter also dinge die gut sind die
wir eigentlich wollen die wir immer
schon wollen
das ist man fährt ja mit ich mit dem
schiff und lädt dort waren ein die
niemand will
es wäre unsinnig also ein schiff mit
waren zu beladen
die per se niemand will das wären keine
güter würden wir nicht nur sagen dass es
güter sind
und selbst wenn es jetzt nur schrott
wäre oder müll oder sonstiges würde man
sagen ja gut da muss man es halt zu
einer mülldeponie bringen dann ist es
auch wieder gut
wir müssen es weg bringen sonst würde
man es halt einfach jetzt merkt gleich
da wäre es aber kein gut zu überlegen
sie nochmal hier also liegt jetzt wo
liegt jetzt die arche an die handlungs
zahl jetzt güter übers ins meer zu
schmeißen zu werfen um das schiff vor
dem kentern zu retten sein leben
zurückblickt ist die arche
noch
in diesem moment bleiben sich erster
mensch
genau das ist eine möglichkeit also wir
könnten ja auch die güter nicht über
bord werfen wir könnten sie einfach
trennen lassen
das wäre eine möglichkeit und jetzt
überlegen das ist jetzt sagen auf der
höchsten ebene da gibt es nur zwei
alternativen entweder wir machen sind
wir machen es nicht
und jetzt überlegen sie mal was ist noch
für eine möglichkeit gibt wie
aristoteles noch argumentieren könnte
dieses betrifft jetzt nicht so sehr die
alternative güte was mehr werfen oder
nicht sondern es gebe auch noch
vielleicht andere möglichkeiten
sieben leben zu können
ja okay so könnte man es auch noch sehen
ja mir kommt jetzt gerade noch eben die
idee dass man prinzipiell wenn sie jetzt
oder sie hatten sie noch gemeint er
der nebel geben möchte
genau also sie haben alle recht es
handelt sich hierbei um mittel das
praktische mittel ich meine mein gedanke
zählt das alles richtig war sagen mein
gedanke erzählte jetzt darauf ab dass
wenn sie jetzt auf dem schiff
verschiedenes haben und könnten sie um
ihr leben zu retten auf verschiedenes
tun sie müssen jetzt nicht vielleicht
nur die güte bord werfen sie könnten
vielleicht auch irgendwas anderes machen
ja ich weiß jetzt nicht aber vielleicht
könnten sie auch wegen wie den mast
umlegen oder irgendwie sowas oder ich
weiß nicht so ein paar sklaven über bord
schmeißen oder sony selbst politisch
unkorrekt ja oder sie könnten ganz
gentleman oder gentleman sie könnten
selbst über bord gehen damit der rest
überlebt hatte es geht ein bisschen ihre
richtung aber sie haben da ganz
verschiedene optionen dann plötzlich das
ist glaube ich diese punkte auf den
aristoteles hier abzielt sie haben dem
zwang sie müssen was tun und sie müssen
wahrscheinlich was tun was ziemlich
unangenehm ist was die normalerweise
nicht täten sie springen die freiwillig
ins wasser das machen sie nicht das
nicht gut und sie sie schmeißen auch
nicht gut an bord oder sie sehen nicht
den ast ab oder machen sonstige dinge
kaputt dann aber wenn es nicht anders
geht sprich stichwort geringeres übel
dann haben sie darin angesichts dieses
zwangsehe aber noch eine gewisse
freiheiten gewisse westliche freiheit
und das könnte man jetzt also das thema
die frage wie nennt man das dann also
man hat nicht mehr die freiheit
natürlich im höchsten sinne weil das die
arche dass das eigentliche zweck der ist
vorgegeben
wir können diesen ursprünglichen anlass
nicht verändern
das ist das problem wir können da nichts
dran machen aber wir können natürlich
angesichts dieser notwendigkeit
verschiedene instrumentell instrumentell
verschiedene mittel erwägen ergreifen
die uns dann zum geringeren überführen
also ich denke das ist durchaus aus dem
gedanken aristoteles hatte schau mal wie
er jetzt weiter argumentiert was
sagt denn ohne weiteres wirft niemand
aus eigenem wollen güterweg wo dies aber
die bedingung dafür ist sich selbst
übrigens zu retten so tut es jeder der
bei verstand ist solche handlungen sind
also gemischt gleichen aber mehr
gewollten okay da ist es also sind
gemischt aber er sagte sie sind mehr
tendenziell also sind handlungen die
sind teilweise und frei und teilweise
nicht gewollt muss man genauer sagen
teilweise gewollt aber das gewollte
überwiegt sagte jetzt hier
gleichen aber mir geworden
[Applaus]
ja ich sehe das auch so
es werden diejenigen die jetzt von ihm
gesagt haben die ist er freiwillig diese
these wurde jetzt aber stores vertreten
man kann genauso sagen gut also
willensfreiheit starken seine willens
frei ist nicht weil der erste grund
unseres willens nicht in uns liegt der
elz uns vorgegeben
jetzt könnte man so argumentiert sagen
vielleicht ist es handlungsfreiheit also
ich kann zwar meinen willen nicht
bestimmen
und ich kann nicht wollen was ich soll
aber ich kann angesichts der vorgabe
kann ich dann das beste draus machen
und hier ist dann meine
handlungsfreiheit main wollen wieder
gegeben er sagt das denn man wählt sie
die mittel in der handlung situation das
ziel einer handlung richtet sich nach
der situation
ja
sehen sie das ähnlich oder dass ihnen
ein
man wird eben nicht abstreiten können
dass das so ein bisschen ist ein
bisschen ja will endlichkeit im spiel
ist
die abas in sein leben zu retten und
lässt ja nicht nur jetzt diese diese
schlechten umstände auf sich wirken
sondern reagiert ja eigentlich darauf
evolutionär man will ja überleben kommt
er wieder natürlich wieder einspielen
also ich würde mal sagen
handlungsfreiheit das wäre ein fall von
handlungsfreiheit mit den modernen
theorien und eben nicht willensfreiheit
und ihr spricht eben daran muss man
gewollt und ungewollt im hinblick auf
die zeitpunkt der handlung sprechen
also noch ein zitat dagegen das wollen
da es dagegen das wollen dass akkus
ihren das ist was durch zwang und
aufgrund von unwissenheit geschieht
dürfte das gewollte hacks hier und
dasjenige als dass sie nie gelten dessen
ursprung im handeln selbst liegt wobei
er die einzelnen bedingungen kennt unter
denen die handlung stattfindet auch noch
so ein punkt er sagt jetzt das gewollte
hat die arche in sich also im gewollten
haben wir den bestimmungsbuch und so
ließ ich sie jedenfalls wir müssen auch
noch einen wissen von den umständen
halten
also wir müssen auch noch ganz klar
unsere motive reflektieren können
also müsste dann noch so ein weiterer
punkt hinzu kommt so was wie reflexion
ist nicht nur abwesenheit von zwang
es kann man sich natürlich fragen
bestimmt aristoteles freiwilligkeit nur
im negativen sinne ist es jetzt nicht
nur negative freiheit das also
freiwilligkeit aber das gewollte eben
nur die abwesenheit von ungewolltem oder
von zwang ist also könnte man fragen ist
das nicht nur eine form von negativer
freiheit die aristoteles wir uns
präsentieren
was sagen sie dazu würden sie sagen das
ist da gibt es auch ein paar mit der
positiven fall ja
das aber im prinzip ist man zudem ihren
angestellten immer so
so ist gefallen
der text kann das
ja also ich glaube sie haben sehr zu
recht auf diese angewiesen auf diese
bewegt prinzip und in dem aristoteles
sagt wir sind nur dann freiwillig aktiv
wenn dieses prinzip in uns ist diese
beweggrund uns selbst sich bemerkbar
macht damit scheint er wieder so ein
positives moment der fall drei zu
bringen er sagt nicht nur freiheit von
äußeren bestimmung gründen sondern
freiwilligkeit muss sein die situation
in der die arche mich selbst liegt worin
wir selbst der grund unseres wollen sind
und da scheint so eine art von positiver
freier ins spiel zu kommen
es gibt es sie gar nicht ausreicht es
besser bei uns vorstellen
genau hier
gut ich meine aristoteles spricht ja
hier also gut er spricht in der
übersetzung spricht er von gewalt kann
man natürlich sagen gut wenn jetzt eben
in mir sie kennen dich nochmal dieses
beispiel dieses böse tracks so hieß
diese person glaube ich bei harry
frankfurt wo es um die alternative
möglichkeiten ging
wenn der jetzt uns so manipuliert dass
wir es einfach wollen dann ist das
natürlich gewollt jedenfalls wenn sie
verweisen zu recht jetzt auf die
freiheit hin und da sagt ja auch herr
hausmann immer noch es gibt dieses
moderne beispiel ein device als es so
ein gerät was sind uns installiert wird
das uns einfach bestimmte wünsche
vorgibt und wir müssten um eine wirklich
überzeugende theorie von willensfreiheit
zu haben
solche fälle ausschließen können wo
einfach irgendwas in uns hinein
gepflanzt wird was dann unser wählen
wollen bestimmt ne wurde eben dass wir
solche fälle haben wie zum beispiel
besucht von der ja auch harry frank
verspricht mit seinem ersten texte
gelesen haben die sicherlich uns auch
wünsche ein gibt aber deren autor wir
selbst nicht hin
jetzt können wir natürlich weiter fragen
inwiefern können wir denn überhaupt
autoren unserer selbst sein
also müssen wir nicht immer schon auf
irgendwas angewiesen sein was vor finde
ich ist was wir gar nicht selbst in der
hand haben können wir uns selbst
erfinden können wir uns aus dem nichts
schaffen
das ist natürlich dieses dilemma der
willensfreiheit oder auch der autonomie
wie sollen wir uns denn selbst ein
gesetz geben und selbst legitimieren
wenn wir um uns eingesetzt geben zu
können
ja schon zahlen müssen das dilemma der
autonomie
also wir setzen wenn wir sagen wir
werden nur dadurch frei dass wir uns
selbst ein gesetz geben
oder wir werden nur dann zu einer
identität wenn wir uns selbst bestimmen
dann setzen wir immer schon unsere
identität voraus dadurch dass wir uns
bestimmt können müssen wir schon als
bestimmungstäter individuen und
letztendlich eigentlich auch als frei
wesen vorliegt das ist das sogenannte
paradox der autonomie also das ist auch
noch so ein problem was ich hier uns
stimmt aber als ich denke sie haben zu
recht darauf hingewiesen diese idee
könnte jetzt prinzipiell ein device sein
oder eine 1 1 ein resultat eines bösen
professors an der bösen professorin die
uns da ein pflanz dann ist die arche in
uns also das prinzip unseres wollen sie
sind uns aber das prinzip des wollens
ist eigentlich etwas was fremdgesteuert
ist oder so da könnte aristoteles immer
noch sagen in dem die arche
fremdgesteuert ist ist sie halt doch
noch von außen bestimmt dann liegt halt
dass die arche dies unsere arche wieder
aus und könnte als tolle sagen na gut
die arche selbst wenn sie uns
eingepflanzt wurde sondern zum chip oder
so seien willens stück der grund für
diesen willens chip.de liegt halt
wiederum außerhalb von uns weil dem
diese böse professoren und dieser böse
profession uns ein geplatzt hat
vielleicht könnte so aristoteles darauf
antworten ja das finde ich ganz
überzeugen dass er sagt es muss einfach
begrifflich in uns liegen
es darf nicht von außen irgendwie
bedingt worden
bisschen abwehr damit den schritt damit
dass keine hindernisse
die aufklärung werde quentin hat der
umgebaute hat
müssen wir noch mal schauen ob mir die
zitate grad haben die tugend spielt
natürlich auch noch eine große rolle ich
schau mal kurz hier
ich denke nicht dass er die freiheit
abwerten würde die freiwilligkeit aber
natürlich erleichtert es uns tugenden in
unserem handeln konstant zu bleiben
aristoteles spricht von dem von der
hexis sie auch immerhin schreibt hexis
die hexis das ist sozusagen die die
haltung oder es geht auch so ein
bisschen charakter in haben also und die
hängt natürlich auch mit der tugend
zusammen eine tugend und sind nichts was
wir nur instanzen ausüben oder ausführen
oder aktualisieren
also jetzt bin ich mal irgendwie
großzügig am morgen nicht mehr
das wäre eigentlich keine richtige zogen
seine methoden damit sie eine tugend ist
setzt voraus dass sie uns zur
angewohnheit geworden ist zur zweiten
natur geworden ist wenn ich tugendhaft
bin bin ich tugendhaft über eine
bestimmte zeit hinweg und nicht nur
heute und morgen oder jetzt mal um immer
um 16 uhr bin ich tugendhaft jeden
freitag jeden zweiten freitag im monat
um 16 uhr bin ich trocken schafft dann
würde niemand sagen dass das tugendhaft
ist jeder würde sagen das schafft so
sein voraussetzt dass über bestimmte
zeit weg am besten sein ganzes leben
lang zu machen oder sich zu entscheiden
es ab jetzt immer in der zukunft zu tun
das ist die tugendhaftigkeit und die
erleichtert es uns in unseren wollen
frei zu sein
weil wir dann nicht jedes mal aufs neue
entscheiden müssen was wir tun sollen
sondern weil wir uns die
handlungsanweisung so zum charakter
gemacht haben dass wir da nicht in jedem
fall noch mal nachdenken müssen sondern
das ist dann ziemlich klar wir sind halt
so ist und so eine art zweiten natur
geworden
so könnte man es vielleicht auch noch
verstehen
und jetzt möchte ich noch mal kurz auf
diese auf diesen vorsatz eingehen auf
die progressive dazu war meine letzten
sitzung nicht mehr gekommen
er sagt nachdem wir das gewollt und das
ungewollte handeln also praktisch das im
heck cia das ist dass die freiwilligkeit
das gewollte und die akku cia ist dass
ungewollte handel definiert haben ist
die nächste aufgabe den vorsatz die
profis zu erörtern
denn der vorsatz gilt als besonders denn
wie der turm verbunden und soll mehr
noch als die handlung praxis
unterschiede im charakter etwas von
menschen anzeigen der vorsatz listen
offensichtlich etwas gewolltes fusion er
ist aber nicht mit dem gewollten
identisch dass eine weitere ausdehnung
hat in einem gewollten haben sowohl
kinder wie auch andere tiere wie auch
die anderen tiere teil am vorsätzlichen
aber nicht und handlungen die wir aus
einer augenblicks laune tun wenn wir
zwar gewollt aber nicht vorsätzlich wie
verhalten sich jetzt vorsatz und
freiwilligkeit oder die wollte seco sion
zueinander
wenn man jetzt mal hier so ein
so einem engen eine menge machen also
praktisch eine schnittmenge oder so
einem engen diagramm jetzt mal machen
wie muss ich das jetzt zeichne ich habe
hier die menge aller gewollten
handlungen und die menge aller
vorsätzlichen angriff
was ist jetzt von was eine teilmenge
wenn ich jetzt dazu zwei kreise ab 2
mengen was muss ich jetzt in was rein
schreiben
eigentlich habe praktisch sieht sich
hatte sich eine große menge nach dieser
stift ist leider nicht mehr so
tugendhaft als aristoteles könnte jetzt
sagen die tugend des stiftes ist jetzt
nicht mehr vorhanden so würde er redet
tugend des stiftes also die arid des
stiftes ist jetzt nicht mehr vorhanden
weil ich damit nicht mehr schreiben kann
so denkt aristoteles allerding tugend
nicht nur auf charakter tugenden bezogen
sondern auch auf gegenstimmen oder auch
auf andere lebewesen zb die tugend die
adt adt bedeutet wie sie ja wissen nur
das gut sein und gut sein im weitesten
sinne also jetzt nicht moralisch gut
seien nur zu den menschen schon aber für
gegenstände bedeutet einfach nur seine
funktion sein ursprünglich zugedachten
zweck gut aus zu führen und das tut
jetzt dieser stift nicht mehr
das lässt natürlich jetzt auf meine
untugend schließen weil ich jetzt nicht
rechtzeitig hier mich im neuen stift
gekümmert haben also die arche liegt
wiederum außerhalb aber das nur ganz
nebenbei gesagt jetzt haben wir eine
große menge
ich hoffe man kann sie noch erkennen
ohne kleine menge hier drin gedacht was
ist jetzt die größere menge als die
kleinere her
[Musik]
genau also wenn etwas ein vorsatz ist
dann ist das gewollt aber es gilt nicht
anders herum dass man etwas gewollt ist
das ist dadurch schon vorsatz ist und
warum jetzt nicht was ist das argument
warum ist es jetzt so warum es jetzt die
menge an der gewollten handlungen größer
als die menge aller vorsätzliche
handlung und warum ist die menge einer
vorsätzlichen handlungen teilmenge der
menge alle wollten als das ist praktisch
gewollt und das ist ein foul vorsätzlich
und man kann erahnen
ja
begrünt werden
ja könnte man sagen genau als geht die
richtige richtung schauen sie mal hier
sagt er hier weil wir das gewollte nur
aus einer augenblicks laune ton und das
daneben gewinnen können aber nicht
vorsätzlich können sie vielleicht noch
mal ein bisschen mit anderen worten
versuchen zu begründen ich glaube sie
waren die richtige richtung
ja ok genau als sie würden sagen das
wäre dann ihre gewollt das eis zu essen
als kind oder als tier wird wenn ein
tier irgendwas sich schnappt aber es
wäre kein vorsatz bei vorsatz müsste
mehrere fraktionen stattfinden was
müsste bei vorsatz noch stattfinden
jetzt im kontrast zur bloßen augenblicks
laune heraus überlegungen genau
reflexionen vielleicht noch ein abwägen
von gründen also was spricht dagegen was
spricht dafür
also es spricht einiges dafür ans netz
zu nehmen spricht doch einiges dagegen
das kostet geld das ist nicht so gesund
könnte auch was anderes von diesem geld
mehr kaufen
ich könnte es auch jetzt noch nicht
essen sondern später vielleicht oder
vielleicht auch gar nicht nur solche
gründe also wenn man diese gründe diese
reflexion hier mit ins spiel bringt dann
hätte man es mit vorsatz ton als
vorletzter ist einfach eine längere
planung schon davor erfolgt und das
gewollte ist er so unmittelbar und
könnte jetzt mal die these aufstellt
dass das gewollte als die hexa nur
handlungsfreiheit ist und die profis
willst was sagen sie denn zu diesen
versuchen leuchtet ihnen das ein also
die frage ist handelt es sich bei der
hassia hierbei der freiwilligkeit bei
dieser großen menge des gewollten um
handlungsfreiheit und bei der praxis
dagegen um willensfreiheit ja
die ezb so geprägt
bis dann später an der hand wurde nicht
mehr neu
auch bleiben
wir hätten hier kann das manchmal
dann würde ich sagen dass das noch
gut also dass spannende frage also wenn
jetzt irgendwas behandlung aus einer
hexe es folgt aus der tugendhaften
charaktereigenschaft ist es dann
überhaupt noch wirklich vorsätzlich zu
nennen ja oder es ist nicht nur sohn
endlose wie soll ich sagen große
anwendung dieses prinzips bloße instanz
dieses prinzips weil ich kann ja gar
nichts anderes wollen als nach dieser
tugend die ich mir jetzt zum charakter
gemacht habe so könnte man argumentieren
wir könnt ihr natürlich auch dagegen
argumentieren sagen aber in dem die
einzelnen handlungen aus meinem
tugendhaften charakter folgen um dieser
tugendhafte charakter oder die tugend in
folge der progressiv oder einer willens
weinhandlung zu eigen gemacht wurde sind
sie mittelbar nicht unmittelbar oder
mittelbar auch wenn es freilich könnte
man sagen weil sie sich eben dieser
dieser hexis verdanken oder dieser
tugend und die tun eben durch wo heißes
irgendwie angenommen wurde vielleicht
wäre eben jeder fall einer art und
haften handlung durch dieses durch die
wahl oder durch die annahme dieses
charakters eben dann vermittelt doch
willens bekannt ist dass sogar immanuel
kant zum beispiel er sagt wir wählen
unsere maximen unsere grundsätze und
diese maxime wählen wir frei und alle
handlungen die diesen maximen folgen
sind dann eben durch diese annahme
dieser maxime eben auch willens frei
sobald es mit maxime zu tun hat
max 7 eben immer schon willens mit
willensfreiheit verbunden sind
da wegen verschiedene optionen
gegeneinander ab wir können unsere
maxime dem sittengesetz über ordnen oder
im sittengesetz unterordnen und indem
wir diese verhältnis bestimmung
vornehmen haben wir hier vielleicht
von kohei risses im spiel ganz vage sagt
ja also das ist doch eine wichtige
unterscheidung zwischen dem bloß
gewollten was ich jetzt mit diesem
hoffentlich etwas besser schreiben
stiftung mit dem geh und her mit dem
vorsatz hier der eine teilmenge ist der
stift entsorge ich jetzt das ist ein
biologisch abbaubarer stift also darf
ich jetzt hier in reston werfen und im
nächsten sitzung vor weihnachten
bekommen sie ein ganz ganz neuen stift
dass mein vorsatz ist mein vorsatz
jedenfalls meine praxis vielleicht
klappt es auch nicht vielleicht
unterliege ich der akku cia dem eine
arche die außen vermittelt ok dann noch
mal was diejenigen die den vorsatz
beginn der epidemie erregung timos
wunsch pullis oder eine art von meinung
doxa nennen scheinen unrecht zu haben
denn der vorsatz ist den vernunft losen
wesen nicht mit uns gemeinsam
regiert und erregung hingegen schon
weiter handel der unbeherrschte der
acatis zwar mit begehren aber nicht mit
vorsatz wären umgekehrt der beherrschte
in cafés mit vorsatz also prozess
handelt aber ohne begierde
ferner steht dem vorsatz die begierde
entgegen aber nicht dirigierte der
begierde bei der bz zitiert er auf das
angenehme hätte und unangenehme der
vorsatz dagegen weder auf das
unangenehme noch das angenehm
ja das haben wir ja noch ein paar
informationen wie unterscheiden sich
jetzt vorsatz von begierde der chemie
der erregung dem teambus und dem wunsch
der polizist
wie verstehen sie den letzten satz dass
ich die profis ist der vorsatz weder auf
das unangenehme noch auf das angenehme
richtet
wollen dann sind sie schon schon lösen
noch nicht
[Musik]
b
man könnte jetzt sagen dass die begierde
die nach aristoteles wie mir scheint mit
dem wollen kompatibel ist nicht populär
ist dass die begierde sich sagt er
jedoch oder das wollen auf das angenehme
und unangenehme bezieht
es geht dem rollenden dem im weiteren
sinne wollen denn hier dieser großen
menge die mal ausgenommen
die kleinere dem geht es um dasjenige
was uns angenehm erscheinen prima fazit
man könnte jetzt mit harry frankfurt
argumentieren das sind wir den stufen
oder desire s erster ordnung
das sind wünsche triebe erste stufe nur
die in trainieren uns die die hardy
ziehen uns an seine ersten stufe man
könnte jetzt sagen die stärkste begierde
die uns am meisten an zieht die gewinnt
halt und das was eben da aller
begehrenswertes erscheint das tue ich
halt und dann folglich eben der begierde
und das wäre wohl nach aristoteles wenn
ich ihn recht verstehe
mit ecosia gleichzusetzen
einfach hier setzt sich eben das
stärkste trieb sagen motiv durch das
kann man sich natürlich wieder fragen
inwiefern liegt dann die arche noch
innig wenn sie doch der stärkste trieb
durchsetzt er könnte man trotzdem seine
guten uns liegt der grund dafür weil wir
einfach dann bestimmen was uns am
meisten an zieht also wenn wir jetzt
eben dann schokoladeneis stadt
erdbeereis wählen dann haben wir hier so
2 trieben uns antrieb ist schokoladen
als ein andere triebes erdbeereis wenn
wir uns für schokoladen eis dann
entscheiden dann liegt der grund
natürlich in uns bei unser charakter in
zur natur so ist sie halt mehr
schokoladeneis mag könnte man sagen das
wäre jetzt aber eben nicht also hier
würden jetzt eben auf diese ersten
ordnung als praktische erster ordnung
nur angenehmes und unangenehmes
abgewogen werden und jetzt sagt
aristoteles aber dass der vorsatz die
profis es geht weder auf das unangenehme
noch auf das angenehme sondern er geht
auf was auf was muss der vorsatz dann
gehen wir dann nicht nur auf das
unangenehme und auch das angenehme
kerzen
vielleicht ja das könnte man sich
überlegen genau also auf das was
jedenfalls mehr mit vernunft zu tun hat
war es nicht so unmittelbar uns hier
vor allem den anspruch nimmt gefangen
was könnte man noch sagen also auf
tugendhafte sachen auf moralische
erwägungen
das können und genau auf die leute
harmonie als auch die glückseligkeit die
nicht wie sie die sagen nicht nur jetzt
hier die unmittelbare triebbefriedigung
oder ihre befriedigung verlangt sondern
die eben auch noch weitere ziele erlaubt
also muss jedenfalls mehr vernunft mit
ins spiel kommen und diese unmittelbare
begierde dieses begehren nicht und jetzt
kennen sie sicherlich alle von platon
dieses seelen modell also es gibt nach
platon drei serienteile weist kann die
von ihnen noch mal jemand nennen nach
plattform welches jeden teile wird dort
haben ja
jedenfalls inzwischen musste
und hier haben wir das jetzt eigentlich
also es ist ein bisschen des
platonischen modell das apogee madcon
das wäre die begierde das ist ganz unter
das ist ja nach politischer ebene ist es
der nähe stand also die bauern sagen die
brücke die von nahrung zuständig sind
dann haben wir den kinos wie würden sie
denn den thymus verstehen das ist dann
in der mitte zwischen dem
logistikkonzern vernunft seelen teilte
das ist der höchste und dem niedrigsten
das ist der mathematiker regierte wie
verstehen wir sollten mit timos
verstehen ganzen idee er sagt ja hier
erregung
häufig wird es auch mit dem mut der mut
hafte als der mut haft serie teil
besitzt
was könnte jetzt denn die erregung oder
der teamboss oder dass das mode haft von
der begierde unterscheiden
am cd wie könnte man das jetzt machen
auch angesichts der tatsache dass
aristoteles und platon vor allem platon
jedenfalls den teams über die bloße
begierde ort also so ein zwischending
zwischen bloßer regierte und zwischen
vernunft erwägung wie könnte man denn
jetzt den sie muss stimmen
und wie verstehen sie erregung
als ganz interessant war in der
geschichte der philosophie
manche interpretinnen und interpreten
gesagt haben dass der typus also das was
zwischen vernunft logistikern und pc
medicon begierde steht so eine vorläufer
theorie der modernen willens theorie sei
also als im thymus eigentlich der
moderne willens begriff wiege ich gebe
aber zu dass platon vision gesellschaft
stand entspricht des zählt der seele
teil des themas wissen sie es noch ja
den wächtern genau alles ganz unten gibt
es die bauern die sind diejenigen die
dem jährlichen seelen teil gleichen oder
entsprechen
dann gibt es auf der ebene des themas
des gut haften sie allen teils gibt es
die wächter und ganz oben auf der ebene
des logistik konnten stehen die
philosophen könige genau
ok jetzt gehen und fragen in dieser
analogie was machen jetzt wächter was
bloß bauern nicht tun um jetzt in dieser
analogie den kinos begriff noch ein
bisschen genauer zu verstehen
scheint mir auch so damit würden sie
seien
dieses
aber frauen
frauen hätten
ich dachte auch an so was sie beherrscht
sie sagt jetzt tugenden zu einem almut
haffter der muss entschieden sein muss
klar in der entscheidung sein der muss
eine gewisse form von toben heftigkeit
schon haben nämlich disziplin die wäre
rechte müssen diszipliniert sein
das heißt sie können sich nicht mehr so
unmittelbar von ihren begierden treiben
lassen aber sie sind natürlich immer
nicht ganz oben weil sie eben immer noch
so ein bisschen mit den begierden in
einem verhältnis stehen sie sind da
immer noch ein bisschen tragen und
deswegen müssen wir nach platon ganz
hoch steigen könnte auch sagen fast
schon aus der höhle des lows jährlichen
über die position des mode haften hinauf
wie beim song wie beim höhlengleichnis
aufsteigen zum zum logistiker das auch
so eine art aufstiegs bewegung also
manche sagen kurz gesagt manche sagen
dass im thymus so eine art von willens
begriff schon angelegt seien im begriff
des capital medicon bestimmt nicht das
ist das bloß begehrlich sagen das
triebhafte und betrieb aber der wille
könnte ihm zum liegen
aber sie sehen ganz klar ist es noch
nicht wir jetzt hier aristoteles schon
so etwas wie den bildungsbegriff kennt
das hängt damit zusammen dass eben drei
sälen teile unterscheidet in deiner
platonischen tradition ist nun aber die
seelen teilen nicht mehr wie es platon
getan hatte als teile gesetzt hat
sondern als stufen also für aristoteles
ist jetzt im gegensatz zu platten so
dass selbst das wenige was einem news
hat also ein vergleich mit dem logistik
und was das der höchsten rationalen
stufe entspricht dass das immer auch
die zwei unteren stufen mit sich
einschließen muss als nicht zählen teil
ist an als seelen stufen
alles was vernünftig ist muss nach zum
beispiel wir menschen muss nach
aristoteles immer auch lebendig sein es
muss auch so was wie einen er sei ja
einen eher seele also einen stoffwechsel
seele und tiere die jetzt eben keinen
vernunft haben nach aristoteles die
müssen auch natürlich diese stoffwechsel
seele haben und was müssen sie noch für
eine seele seele stufe haben wissen sie
dass es noch für eine stufe gibt also
nicht nur dann die praktische
stoffwechsels und auch noch die bewegung
das ist auch noch ganz wichtig dass man
all sorts änderung erreichen kann das
jetzt als ein kleiner exkurs sie sehen
also hier gibt's in der antike schon
große der früh antike sozusagen große
debatten jetzt wie man das wollen
bestimmen soll
man könnte jetzt als fazit sagen diese
freiwilligkeit also die heco sia könnte
so etwas wie handlungsfreiheit sein und
die vhs es könnte sogar sein wie wiens
freiheit man könnte natürlich sagen gut
das war ihr beispiel wenn jetzt aber
eben die arche eingepflanzt wurde
in mich dann hab ich ja dieses wollen
und selbst wenn ich darüber reflektieren
ist es dann noch frei werden wir da
diesen ganzen bedingungen gerecht ich
glaube auch nicht aber es geht so ein
bisschen richtung will das hat noch was
sie tat noch weniger aber ist der
vorsatz bewegung den handlungen aufgrund
von erregung gelten am wenigsten
vorsätzlich als interessant also hier
sagt jetzt offen sich dass der vorsatz
wohl noch mehr mit den mit der begierde
kompatibel sei als mit den dem tumors
mit dem der erregung
das passt jetzt also nicht mehr ganz so
harmonische bild der vorsatz ist aber
auch nicht mit dem wunsch des anderen
das hat mit dem wunsch identisch obwohl
er ihm ähnlich ist denn ein vorsatz
bezieht sich nicht auf unmögliches und
wenn jemand sagen würde dass er sich
unmögliches von ihm würde man ihn für
dumm halten wünschen hingegen kann man
auch etwas unmögliches zb die
unsterblichkeit und der wunsch bezieht
sich auch auf dinge die man auf keine
weise durch eigenes handeln herbeiführen
kann
etwa dass ein bestimmter schauspiel oder
athlet gewinnen möge dass solche dinge
nimmt sich niemand vor sondern nur
diejenigen dinge von denen man meint
dass sie durch eigenes handeln zustande
kommen kann
ferner der wunsch bezieht sich mehr auf
das ziel tellers der vorsatz mehr auf
das was zum ziel führt ab rostock
tellers wir wünschen zb gesund zu sein
doch wir nehmen uns die dinge vor durch
die wir gesund werden und wir wünschen
glücklich zu sein und sagen auch dass
wir es wünschen während man nicht gut
sagen kann dass wir uns vornehmen
gerichtet sein
überhaupt scheint der vorsatz das zum
gegenstand zu haben was in unserer macht
steht noch mal eine ganz wichtige
unterscheidung die wir auch bei harry
friend wird gefunden haben nämlich die
unterscheidung zwischen wunsch und wille
gegen diese richtung also vorsatz
scheint jetzt doch in der differenz zum
bloßen wunsch der politik also vorsatz
jetzt als profi risses ihr den modernen
willens begriffs entsprechend warum was
ist jetzt noch mal der unterschied nach
aristoteles zwischen dem bloßen wunsch
und den willen oder der dem vorsatz was
können wir im wünschen tun was wir im
vorsätzlichen nicht können
genau wir können uns alles mögliche
wünschen auch das was wir hier sagt auf
keine weise durch eigenes handeln
herbeiführen können wir können uns alles
wünschen aber ob wir es auch wollen
können das die fragen man neigt dazu zu
sagen man kann nur das wollen wozu man
auch die mittel hat wozu auch die mittel
angeben kann um zu seinem ziel zu
gelangen
und das kann man durch bei manchen
wünschen nicht
jetzt überlegen ist immer folgendes dazu
bleiben ein beispiel
der wunsch aller er bringt jetzt
beispiel das ist mein wunsch sei dass
ein bestimmter schauspieler gewinnen
möge er sagt jetzt und das liegt nicht
in unserer macht
wann würde denn dann dieser wunsch jetzt
in diesem beispiel um mit diesem
beispiel zu bleiben dann würde dieser
wunsch zum wille werden nehme man lässt
sich den schauspielern den athlet sie
haben den wunsch dass athleten iks die
olympischen spiele gewinnt haben sie den
wunsch sie sitzen in olympia am rand und
einem schönen großen baum beschattet von
der sehr starke sonne und wissen jetzt
bald findet der wettlauf statt wo die
athletin von der sie wollen dass sie
gewinnt mit läuft es sehr wunsch wie
kann jetzt dieser wunsch zu ihrem wille
werden das müssen sie jetzt unternehmen
damit der bloße wunsch zu einem wille
wird
genau das können sie jetzt zum beispiel
ton damit ihr bloß bestechend genau sie
bestechen den schiedsrichter ganz klar
natürlich kann man sich fragen hat dann
die athletin noch gewonnen eigentlichen
sinne ja gut nach dem offiziellen regeln
offiziellen reden aber wenn sie bekommt
man halt den preis
sie wird geehrt wenn es jemand mehr
wenn es natürlich raus kommt in der
heutigen mittel zeiten machen könnte man
sagen doping haben tobt sich einfach
also sieht man die frage ist inwieweit
man es in der hand hat und sie merken
sobald ist zu einem wille wird merken
sie das sind sie entschieden sind also
viel entschieden da sie wünschen sich
nicht nur sowieso ein traum sind sie
sind entschieden
und sie denken nach und sie geben sich
die konkreten mittel an die zu ihrem
ziel führen also erst muss ich mir geld
besorgen dann muss ich irgendwie in
kontakt zum schiedsrichter herstellen
und musste ihn irgendwie stechen ich
muss ihn reden und so und dann wird sehr
viele hinsicht die ganze kette von
mittel zweck relation angeben können das
ist eine in unter umständen sehr lange
kette wie sie zu ihrem wunsch gelang es
ihr ziel gelangen und dann ist es ein
will dann ist aus diesem wunsch der bloß
schwebend ist ein konkrete wille
geworden so einfach ist es einfach ein
bisschen bestechen das hat fast hätte es
nicht für möglich gehalten
ok ich glaube das können wir jetzt ein
bisschen überspringen und jetzt kommen
wir zu diesem netten herrn hielt er aber
nicht aristoteles heißt sondern
augustinus war natürlich nur ein test um
sie zu prüfen
aber sie sehen die jahreszahlen die sind
korrekt hier nämlich jetzt springen wir
von der früh antike als vom vierten
vorchristlichen jahrhundert in dem
aristoteles gelebt hat ins vierten
nachchristlichen jahrhundert in dem
augustinus gelebt hatte und der hat eine
schrift verfasst die heißt die libero
api trio und hier kommen jetzt ganz neu
begriffe ins spiel die ich ihnen an die
tafel schreiben würde wenn meine schrift
funktionieren würde ich habe jetzt also
den wunsch ich habe den wunsch aber
nicht den willen einen funktionsfähigen
stift jetzt in der hand zu haben
ich habe deswegen nicht in villen mal
wenn ich ihn hätte würde ich jetzt kurz
hoch laufen wir holen das mache ich
jetzt auch nicht dass also nun wunsch
okay hier kommen jetzt ein neuer begriff
ins spiel nämlich das atrium lieferung
des atrium hier verschiebt sich jetzt
was hier ist diesmal wird jetzt auf
latein geschrieben
es ist nunmal griechisch und das abitur
habe ich jetzt mehr gesetzt mit
entscheidungswegen kennen sie ein
englisches wort in dem irgendwie auch
eine spur von atrium enthalten ist
und wir kennen sie ein anderes wort ein
deutsches wort vielleicht auch atrium
drin ist das sind fremd war natürlich
genau wie trainer
das heißt ein abitur
gegensätzlich ja mir nicht ganz sicher
haben sie vielleicht noch andere ideen
was apetri heißen wenn ich glaube es
ging die richtige richtung aber genau
oder beliebig genau zum beispiel sagt
man häufig dass bei zeichen etwas abitur
ist sollte das laut bild von bedeutung
tragen zeichen oder zeichen
grundsätzlich sind häufig abitur zb das
kennen sie aus der linke ist dass ich
zum beispiel sagen deutschen stuhl also
wort oder das laut bild stuhl um einen
stuhl zu bezeichnen ist er ich könnte
auch sagen auf englisch würde sähe
bezeichnen ich könnte auch sagen tisch
könnte ich auch sagen es laut bild tisch
und damit den stuhl zu zeigen wenn wir
uns darauf einigen dass dies laut bild
tisch und die zeichenkette tisch und
stuhl bedeutet auch für dich okay dass
das wird häufenden linguistik als abitur
zeigt also man sagt ja häufig
willkürlich willkürlich wie ich schon
sagt in der ersten sitzung hat aber
sonst ganz negativen beigeschmack
mein willkürlich heißt ach es ist völlig
beliebig heute nenne ich so morgen nicht
so damit jetzt natürlich nicht gemeint
aber arbeitnehmer in eben nicht
notwendig kontingent könnte man auch
kontingent und hier ist es jetzt so dass
atrium ist einfach das freie
entscheidung vermutet dass auch manchmal
hängt es auch damit zusammen das
urteilsvermögen als atrium wird häufig
auch mit urteilsvermögen gleichgesetzt
das werth urteil fällen können und darin
freisen und jetzt gehen wir mal hier auf
seinen dialog das irgendwie dialog und
zwar zwischen 2
denn kann aber erst sind fragen noch
inwiefern ist der mensch nach augustinus
williams frei wie verhalten sich will
und vernunft zueinander und wie fern ist
die freiheit des menschen mit gottes
vorher wissen kompatibel hier kommt er
jetzt noch wenn es um determinismus und
freiheit geht noch eine weitere
dimension ins spiel nämlich die
theologische die für die
früh antiken nicht so eine große rolle
spielte also es geht es um den dialog
zwischen august und videos wissen sie
wir der evos ist oder war musste auch
google das war auch so ein bischof der
damaligen zeit eine augustinus war ja
auch ein bischof von hippo hypo hat
jetzt erst mal nichts mit dem hypo
potter muss zu tun mit dem nilpferd die
polen bei einer stadt wissen sie wo die
stadt hypo lag oder liegt wissen sie das
ja genau
in nordafrika und nach damaliger
redeweise war das nur medien also wo die
lieder lebt es ist ganz erstaunlich das
erste christentum hat seine blüte eben
nicht in europa bekommen zu dieser zeit
jedenfalls nicht im vierten jahrhundert
das seien eben in nordafrika als im
mittelmeerraum und die großen
europäischen theologen kamen eigentlich
erst dann wirklich ins spiel auch was
theoretische entwürfe angelangt also
christo logische entwürfen wie man jetzt
die person christi verstehen muss oder
auch bei der trinität spekulation
autoritäts theorie in der zeit so um 800
also karl der große ein bisschen früher
die fränkischen das waren die
fränkischen theologen und erst im
siebten achten jahrhundert hat europa
mit dem mittelmeer kulturen mithalten
können was auch christliche theologie
theologie begann sehr erstaunlich also
dass eben das erste christentum doch
sehr stark im sogar nordafrika
vorzufinden war und jetzt sagte
augustinus
dialog mit dem fuß und das ist jetzt der
punkt auf den ich eigentlich heute nur
zu sprechen kommen möchte ja sagt ebenso
wie wir alles was wir als zum wissen
gehörig erkennen durch die vernunft
erkennen und trotzdem auch die vernunft
selbst zudem zählen was wir durch die
vernunft erkennen so handelt sich auch
mit dem willen sagt oder hast du es
vergessen dass du zu gegeben hast auch
die vernunft werde durch die vernunft
erkannt als wir fragen was durch die
vernunft erkannt wird und jetzt kommt
der ganz entscheidende satz wundere dich
also nicht dass wenn wir das übrige
durch den freien willen gebrauchen wir
auch den freien willen selbst durch ihn
selbst gebrauchen können so dass sich
der wille der das übrige gebraucht in
gewisser weise selbst gebraucht wie sich
der verstand selbst erkennt der auch das
übrige erkennt auch das gedächtnis
umfasst nicht nur all das übrige an dass
wir uns erinnern sondern auch das was
wir nicht vergessen dass wir nämlich ein
gedächtnis haben das gedächtnis selbst
hält sich in uns fest so dass es sich
nicht nur an das andere sondern auch an
sich selbst erinnert oder besser wir uns
durch das gedächtnis sowohl an das
übrige als auch an das gedächtnis selbst
das ist das allerwichtigste zitat
behaupte ich jetzt mal aus der gesamten
schrift die liebe drin
das bekommen sie jetzt hier auf schöne
weise grund mit grüner schrift
präsentiert
natürlich ein sehr kompliziertes zitat
was wie kann man das jetzt hier
verstehen also was mir jetzt wichtig ist
ist wohl hier sagt wundere dich also
nicht dass wenn wir das übrige durch den
verein will gebrauchen
was können wir dann außerhalb des will
es noch frei gebrauchen haben sie etwas
können durch den willen gebraucht
was lässt sich durch den willen
gebrauchen
was kann in der wille gebrauchen
ja genau
genau in der extension 8
man kann diese frage zu formulieren was
kann ich eigentlich alles wollen oder
willentlich beeinflussen ich kann also
so redet davon gebrauchen gebrauchen ist
de roos als ich kann zum beispiel will
endlich beeinflussen wie sie richtig
sagen meine jeder bewegung ich kann den
arm heben ich kann den finger auf diesen
diese taste drücken und dann ergibt sich
so ein schöner roter laser punkt der
hier jetzt über die grüne schrift
hinwegfliegt ich kann aber auch
willentlich kontrollieren dann könnte
auch sagen wie ländliche kontrolle wäre
auch noch so süß als als system der
gebrauch team ist das deponie das verb
ich kann natürlich auch meine vernunft
will endlich gebrauchen wieder zum
beispiel überlegen sie mal wie kann ich
meine vernunft willentlich kontrollieren
haben sie ein beispiel wo mein wille die
vernunft gebraucht
richtig genau also ich will jetzt über
das nachdenken ja zb ich will jetzt eben
das aus dem bloßen wunsch ein bild wird
und dann will jetzt mein wille jetzt
rede ich natürlich ein bisschen seltsam
der wille will kann man das so sagen
dann will jetzt ich rede es trotzdem
also dann will der wille dass meine
vernunft wie jetzt die mittel gibt um
der athletin zum sieg zu verhelfen
denn gebraucht mein wille die vernunft
dem die vernunft jetzt der wille der
metaphorische dass er ja sehr personal
realisiert indem die vernunft dem willen
jetzt die mittel kommuniziert die dazu
nötig sind um das ziel des bildes zu
erreichen also holte jetzt erst mal das
geld hier und dann geht es im
schiedsrichter übrigens auch
lateinischen anbieter heißt anbieter ist
auch der schiedsrichter im lateinischen
als es der der ein begründetes urteil
fällt das atrium hat immer was mit einem
labor teils fällungen zu tun allerdings
zu dem schiedsrichter und dann gibt es
das geld dann redest du da auf ihn ein
und irgendwann kommst du zu deinem ziel
da die vernunft an dem willen gehorchte
wille hat die vernunft gebraucht okay
aber jetzt ist das entscheidende die
entscheidende frage ist jetzt wie kann
jetzt der wille sich selbst brauchen
gebrauchen
in gewisser weise selbst gebraucht wie
geht das
haben sie denn
alles geht jetzt darum dass der wille
jetzt nicht die vernunft kontrolliert
sondern der wille sich selbst konnte das
überlegen sie mal wie kann der wille
sich selbst kontrollieren
reden sie doch dazu darüber mal kurz
zwei minuten mit ihre nebensitzerin oder
mit ihrem leben setzen zu welchen
ergebnissen sind sie jetzt gelangt was
die frage anbelangt oder inwiefern der
wille sich selbst gebrauchen kann
haben sie die ich habe gehört sie haben
sich intensiv ausgetauscht sowie einfach
zu rufen
bitte
jetzt vernommen kontrolliert
die sagt er
ok oder punkt ja also ich sagen
praktisch damit der wille sich selbst
auf das beziehen kann müsste er die
vernunft mit den spielen nehmen oder
müsse die vernunft eine rolle spielen
wie sehen sie das gerne so guter punkt
gibt es noch weitere meinungen dazu oder
interpretations vorschläge sehr keine
klare sache zuerst ein bisschen paradox
ich will nicht zu bestätigen
dann habe ich jetzt
dezember letzten jahres kommen bereits
in der kommenden single ist
das ist glaube ich auch ein sehr
zentraler punkt in diese richtung gehen
scheint es zu gehen also viele
interpretieren jetzt augustinus sowie
harry frankfurt seine unterscheidung
vorgenommen zwischen begehren erster
stufe und volition zweiter stufe also
nach einem interpretations modell ich
sage jetzt nicht dass das das richtig
ist aber in der forschung wird das so
häufig gesehen meint dieses sich selbst
gebrauchen mehr oder weniger die
ausbildung von volition zweiter stufe
dass ich also über meine bekehrungen
reflektieren alter wäre praktisch der
wille so verstanden erst mal nur das was
in mir unmittelbar trieb mäßig vorliegt
also meine app navigieren oder wünsche
ja auch immer das was mich unmittelbar
etwas hintreibt und der wille würde dann
auf sich selbst reflektieren wenn er
sich eben dann an bestimmten grundsätzen
orientieren oder wie zum beispiel
moralischen erwägungen würde ich also
sagen kann ich das wirklich wollen
natürlich kommt dann bestimmt wieder die
vernunft im spiel auch aber es wäre denn
auch der wille der in seiner art
konflikt geraten würde
nur glaube ich müsste man ihn so lesen
sie hatten jetzt zwei optionen gebracht
der wille kann in einen konflikt geraten
von zwischen zwei motiven die auf
derselben ebene angesiedelt sind so das
wäre das beispiel bei robot game finden
sich da gibt's die geschäftsfrau die
möchte einerseits ihre karriere
weiterverfolgen man im bild bei einem
meeting oder gibt es aber die situation
da sie auf dem weg eine hilfsbedürftige
person sieht und sie ist hin und
hergerissen zwischen moralischen motiven
und karriere mäßigen motiv das wäre auf
derselben ebene
ich glaube dass das damit nicht gemeint
ist sondern es sind motive oder sind
willens tendenzen auf verschiedenen
ebenen
es ist also durchaus vorstellbar dass es
so ein konflikt gibt auf der ersten
ebene
und dann eben von einer zweiten willens
ebene dazu dann noch mal bezug genommen
wird
auch das dementierte gesteuert sind
aber lang
im gegensatz zum getränk
neben
die lösung kann bei nicht machen
ja es ist ein guter punkt wir haben hier
bei augustinus eigentlich ein ähnliches
problem wie bei harry frankfurt mit
diesem regress ja also wieso sollte es
sollte er dann aufhören auf dieser stufe
das wird vielleicht jetzt zu weit im
detail probleme aber man kann sich das
so vorstellen
wir werden einen tag von irgendwas
angezogen da gibt's jetzt schokoladeneis
im sommer und sie wollen es irgendwie
sie begehren ist irgendwie und dann
halten sie inne und fangen sich will ich
das wirklich will ich das wirklich und
dann kommt in ihnen so eine maxime
vielleicht ins spiel
die könnte lauten hoppla ich habe mir
doch an silvester vorgenommen das ganze
nächste jahr kein schokoladeneis müssen
doch jetzt fast ein schokoladeneis
fasten dass meine maxime und diese
maxime stellt jetzt eine willen struktur
höherer ordnung da könnte man sagen und
dann hätten sie hoppla okay jetzt
verhält sich meine maxime oder mein
wille insofern er durch die maxime
bestimmt ist zu meinem willen sofern er
durch das begehrt die begierde bestimmt
ist und dann würden würde man unter
umständen sagen oder wahrscheinlich den
meisten film ok die maxime gewinnt
erinnere ich mich daran
ich beziehe mich auf meinen willen der
wille bezieht sich also an die maxime
des willens bezieht sich auf die
unmittelbare begierden des willens und
sagt an verstrichen
nein du lieber wille darfst jetzt nicht
schokoladen als worden das ist zwar
wollen aber du kriegst es nicht sondern
jetzt setzt sich hier meine maxime ruhig
so könnte man es doch verstehen
das wäre natürlich jetzt insofern
problematisch als wir dann uns zu zwei
akteure in uns vorstellen
es gibt da so ein kleine billens
personen die will immer so das
schokoladeneis die will immer so die
unmittelbaren bekehrungen demnach geben
die will dass das der wille wird
und dann gibt's halt und ihr ich sage
jetzt nicht vernünftigen will aber es
geht in ihre richtung
da ist natürlich bei den höher stufigen
willens tendenzen immer die vernunft ein
bisschen eine stärkere rolle zu spielen
scheint oder so eine weitsichtige wo der
rationale moment ins spiel kommen die
sagt nein ich hatte mir die maxime
gewählt ich will fasten und das ist ein
viel höheres motiv als jetzt das motiv
was mich jetzt dazu treibt schokoladen
eis zu essen würde es ihnen ein leuchter
oder hätten sie dann noch probleme mit
seiner auffassung
richtig er sagte hier wie wir auch den
freien willen durch ihn selbst
gebrauchen können
hier ist natürlich jetzt immer die frage
meinte er dass jetzt so dass wir auf der
ersten stufe den freien willen haben und
von einer zweiten stufe dann nochmal der
freiwillig oder meint er redet er hier
zweimal von verschiedenen dingen die
eigentlich den willen betreffen also man
könnte es jetzt auch so verstehen dass
der freie wille der wille ist der jetzt
der eigentlich frei ist aber die jetzt
erst mal eben nur durch mit ihr stehen
es ist zwar der freiwillig wird jetzt
erst mal eben nur in kliniken am ende
erweist er sich als freier weil wir eben
dadurch dass er eigentlich frei ist auf
den reflektieren können jetzt so
verstehen dass er hier mit dem erst mit
dem freien willen meint der wille unter
der bedingtheit der begierde als freier
wille weil er eben eine zweite stufe von
reflexion ermöglicht könnte man sagen
aber sie haben schon recht es ist ein
bisschen sehr schwer zu verstehen wenn
er eben erst mal vom freien willen als
solchen spricht dann denkt man erst mal
nicht gleich daran dass das nur
begierden sein würden aber also es gibt
hier eben eine interpretation tendenz
die sagt das sollte man so ein bisschen
verstehen wir hier in frankfurt oder
anders gesagt es ist so dass wir das
sagen
harry frankfurt hat das eigentlich von
augustinus übernommen
stillschweigen als erst dadurch ganz
stark bei 1
reflexion smid also das ist sondern sind
die die kern angelegenheit und hier
könnte man jetzt sagen dass jetzt hier
augustinus ebene ganz stark
unterscheidung nach zwischen
handlungsfreiheit und willensfreiheit
handlungsfreiheit ist eben das dass man
diesen schokoladen eis essen wollen
nachgibt unmittelbar und willensfreiheit
wäre dann eben noch mal darauf zu
reflektieren kann ich das wirklich
wollen will ich das wirklich
das ist so eine interpretation richtung
die es gibt sagt hier an dieser stelle
entsteht ein reflex iwes wollen dass ich
der wille selbst reflektiert also dass
man selbst auf seine motive will endlich
reflektiert sicherlich unter einschluss
des vermögens der vernunft und also hier
ist die geburtsstunde der
willensfreiheit bei augustinus zu finden
da wir jetzt ganz am ende sind zwar noch
ein wort allgemein zu augustinus
augustinus könnte man jetzt wenn man es
ganz prägnant sagen möchte vorstellt als
den denker der reflexivität oder denker
der subjektivität bei augustinus sind
alle sehen vermögen reflexiv auch die
vernunft wie hier bereits gesagt wird
auch das gedächtnis dass die moria auch
die das gedächtnis kann sich an das
gedächtnis erinnern und eben auch das
wollen kann sich an das wollen auf das
wurde will endlich beziehen
das hängt damit zusammen wenn sie das
nicht mal genauer anschauen das
augustinus ein sehr sehr komplexen
begriff des geistes hat geist ist hier
mit aristoteles und demenz ist die mails
ist nach aristoteles drei gegliedert
weiß jemand von ihnen welche drei
vermögen dazu gehören bei augustinus zum
geist 2 haben wir schon
die moria die wohl und haas wissen sie
was noch dazu gehört hat sie mal was
können noch dazu gehört
[Applaus]
danach ließ man offen für die nächste
sitzung also es gehört drei vermögen
dazu und nicht und ich zufälligerweise
preis und drei deswegen bei aris august
ihr bei augustinus sagt der menschliche
geist ist ein abbild der realität gottes
also im menschlichen geist unserer
geistigen struktur spiegelt sich in
gewisser weise gottes dreieinigkeit hat
sie mensch ist ein abbild gottes das
gibt es ja in der bibel steht dass er
drin
sophie nach seinem bilde und augustinus
interpretiert das jetzt sehr sehr
differenziert im sinne eines des
theologischen vermögens von einer ganz
komplexen struktur des geistes der eben
auch willentlich im moment enthält ist
es ganz wichtig bei augustinus der geist
ist nichts bloß rationales nicht nur hat
nicht nur zu tun mit einsicht sind auch
mit wollen
das ist die ganz große neuerung bei
augustinus dass der wille also
entschieden aufgewertet und der wille
ist ein moment des geistes das zeigt der
wille ist immer auch mit vernunft
verbunden und mit erinnerung und mit
reflexion
das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig und das
war bei platon noch nicht so platt gibt
es zwar auch die seelen teile aber die
serienteile diesen tieren so einer
hierarchie zum hierarchie verhältnis von
unterdrückung und kontrolle und bei
augustinus ist das ganze dann ist der
wille viele haben
er will jetzt auf eine selben stufe
eigentlich wie die vernunft er wird auch
reflexiv und die vermögen verstand und
wille die harmonisieren bei augustinus
viel mehr als bei platon der pfannes das
nur als eine kurze zusammenfassung im
nächsten nächsten sitzung gehen wir noch
mal kurz darauf zurück und will mich
nicht täusche werden wir dann jetzt
einen ganz entscheidenden schritt in
richtung neuzeit unternehmen aber ich
werde noch mal kurz die zusammenfassung
geben
augustinus theorie des geistes
dann bis zur nächsten zu haben